-Um, you have a wonderful
Melania Trump impression.
But you have a take
on Ivanka Trump.
-Well, I've been noticing
actually, our good friend,
Amy Poehler was the one that
pointed it out to me lately.
She sent, like,
one of her many interviews
where she was talking
about something.
Oh, it was when she said
she wasn't involved in --
She doesn't get involved
in "politics."
'Cause that makes sense.
-Yeah, she's not involved
in politics.
-No, well, they're "politics."
'Cause that makes sense, too.
-Like you're an advisor
to the president.
-She's an advisor
to a president.
But not into politics.
-We get it. We get it.
But she pointed out,
she was like,
"There's a lot of whispering
going on."
And so I noticed, like,
she was, like,
[ Softly ] through her teeth,
but she, like, kind of talks
like she has, like,
a sexy secret.
[ Laughter ]
She's, like, always talking
like she works in
a lingerie store little bit.
[ Laughter ]
Like, if you want to get
the matching panties,
you can get them,
but they're "$14.95."
[ Laughter ]
Also don't quote stuff
that's real
because that just makes you
look really stupid.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And then
everything was like a grin.
Like, I'm sorry,
do you have a sexy secret?
[ Laughter ]
-It's fun to have someone
around who has a sexy --
-It's fun to have a sexy secret.
-You know what else is fun?
-Hmm?
-Wigs.
-Oh, God.
-So, when you met
with Lorne Michaels...
-Yeah.
-This is your meeting,
like, basically he's seen
your audition,
he's liked your audition,
and he brings you in to kind of
get a sense of you.
-It was the world's
worst job interview
I've ever had in my life.
-Yeah.
-Like on my death bed,
I'm gonna be like, "I remember
that, it was so bad."
But I was sitting
in Lorne's office
and he actually asked me
the question,
"Why do you think
you should work here?"
And I said,
"Because I like wearing wigs."
-Wow. And that was it, though.
-Good one, Maya.
-Yeah.
-And that got me the job.
-This actually brings us
to a new segment on the show.
This is the first time
we're doing it
and we're really only probably
ever going to do it with you.
[ Laughter ]
-It's gonna live and die.
Please welcome
to "Basket O'Wigs."
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So we had a friend,
dear friend of ours,
James Anderson,
a writer on "SNL."
He always had a basket of wigs
in his office.
-God bless him always.
-And what would happen,
you're just gonna grab
a wig at random.
You can grab glasses here
if you want.
-Thank you.
-And you're just gonna let it
just create a character.
-By the way,
this is something
that would have happened
without an audience
up in James' office.
-Oh, yeah.
-All right,
I'm gonna go through
the basket of wigs.
Well, I guess I'll start
at the top.
Here we go. That makes sense.
-Yeah.
-It also looks like
one of those --
this looks like one of those
things you get
in a baseball game
that's like the player's hair
on top of your hair.
Maybe that makes more sense.
Seth, where's my breffix?
[ Laughter ]
-Do you need your glasses?
They're right in front of you.
-Oh, thank goodness.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so hungry!
Why won't you feed me
my breffix?
-Grandma, your breffix
has been out all morning.
It's the eggs
that you asked for.
-I can't remember a thing!
-Okay, that's great.
I like that.
-Wow, this game is sending me
to wig heaven.
[ Applause ]
I want you to pick one now.
-All right,
I'm going to pick one.
Uh, I'm gonna do this.
There. No glasses.
-I can't wait to see, like,
Hugh Jackman do this segment
when he comes.
And all the Trumps.
-[ Deep voice ]
"Where's my breffix?"
-[ Laughs ]
Um, guys, I just need
to tell you something.
Someone threw up in the hallway.
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot of vomit
in the hallway.
And I'm not cleaning it up.
So whoever's responsible
is going to have to go home.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ] That's great.
-Thank you.
-I really like that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
Sadly, I feel like
I've worn this wig before.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I definitely have.
I keep trying to check out
the monitor like it's a mirror.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Ba-ba-ba-ba, ba-ba-ba-ba,
baby ♪
♪ Don't forget my number ♪
[ Laughter ]
Nobody remembers Milli Vanilli?
Just me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-♪ Basket o' wigs ♪
-♪ Basket of wigs ♪
-♪ Coming to you live ♪
♪ From Seth Meyers ♪
Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-I [Laughs]
-First date. First date.
-Um, I just want to be clear
on your Tinder,
it said you --
you like breath mints,
but you don't like to eat them.
-[ Muffled ] I like to keep them
in my mouth until they dissolve.
[ Laughter ]
-Joshua, that's the most
fascinating thing about you.
[ Laughter ]
-And is it true
that you're a model
for the people
who make mannequins?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. They use my body
as the shape,
and my face for the inspiration.
[ Laughter ]
-"Basket O'Wigs, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maya Rudolph, everybody.
"The Emoji Movie"
in the theaters July 28th.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."
♪ Basket o' wigs ♪
-♪ Basket o' wigs ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]